[Music]
john's with us in sacramento hey john
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave and george i appreciate you
guys taking my call sure i'll start off
with my
general question which is i have a 45
000 bonus i'll be getting this month and
i'm trying to figure out if i should put
it towards our mortgage completely or
divide it up into putting into some
mutual funds in addition
the general information about us since
my wife and i are 34 years old we have
one child and one on the way yay
yeah yeah very exciting boy and a girl
and our take home after taxes and
putting 15 percent into retirement
after both of those is 8 500 a month
and we have a hundred thousand in the
bank uh 70 000 in our retirement
accounts and we're debt free except for
our house
and so i'm just trying to gain plan um
we have 200 000 left to pay off on our
health and we have a plan that we want
to implement um
to pay off our house in the next six
years by the time we're 40 which we can
do
um but trying to figure out if i should
how big is your bonus that was
45 000.
and you got a hundred thousand dollars
in the bank
and you make what you meant you make 85
she make 140 000 a year
uh yes okay
so
let me get this straight what's the 100k
doing in the bank
um we were stockpiling money for a long
time until we pivoted to recently to
trying to put a bunch more money into
our retirement instead
okay
well you've got 200 yeah
there's something we should change
yeah you've got no debt right
except the house
and you've got 145 000 do you have any
um do you have any money other than the
hundred thousand like for an emergency
fund
uh the hundred thousand would
i guess include our markets about the
emergency but we we also have 75 000 in
retirement accounts yeah so what do you
think your emergency fund should be
uh for six months um assuming that we
live slimly for that time if we needed
it it would be about thirty thousand
dollars
okay so you got 70 left plus the 45 so
you're looking at 115
you could use towards this house
yeah leaving you with 85k on the
mortgage so you're debt-free in two
years not six years
sure i'm excited i'm thinking about it i
hadn't thought about it that way i i i
admittedly i think my wife and i like
stuffing a lot of money under the pillow
so to speak but that's that's a habit
we're currently trying to break which is
part of the reason why i'm calling it
well it's not a bad habit i'll just tell
you that um
the reason that you're doing that is the
security gland
you know and down in your belly is
telling you to i feel secure when i do
that and i will tell you someone who's
done both either put money under the
pillow or paid off my house uh that
paying off your house gives you much
more satisfaction for the security gland
than the pillow does
you you know you know how you kind of
feel if you had 200 000 under the pillow
sure if you'll 2x that feeling that's
the way it's going to feel when you pay
off your house
paying off your house is even more cool
for your security gland than your pillow
is that's what i'm saying
yeah yeah for sure you can't know that
until you do it but that's coming for
you i can see that in your future and
that's what i want for you so that you
can go become very wealthy now you need
to start putting 15 of your income away
into retirement steady as a part of your
401k but that's a part of a budget not a
part of a lump sum thing
you said you're already doing that and
we started doing that yeah we started
doing that a couple years ago oh i
missed that i apologize i'm sorry okay
okay
yeah so i'm with george i'm with george
let's put a 100
yeah let's put 120 130 000 or something
like that on this
house and then let's line up and knock
off that other 70 grand making
140 uh i don't know
two years you're debt-free right
yeah and you've got meantime you're
sitting on 50 grand with no payments in
the world you make 140 your life's
pretty dead gum good man you're doing
well way to go oh and the baby's on the
way woohoo yeah life is great yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah not not too shabby that's for sure
i will tell you this if you pay off your
house
and you hate being debt-free you can go
get a mortgage they'll let you
yeah i i so i've heard from many
i think there's a little uh you can get
paralyzed with all the decisions well i
could do this and i could put it in
mutual funds and i could do this and
what i love about the baby steps is it
just filters everything and gives you
this clear view of how to approach money
and for me that's pay off the house
first and then you can invest yeah and
it's exactly right and he's got a great
question but and your point about the
baby steps is this
it is the fastest
easiest
way to become a millionaire
which is the underlying question not not
not that i need to be a millionaire okay
but the fastest easiest way to wealth
okay so that i can do all the things
that wealth will do like we're talking
about a minute ago but the fastest
easiest way is important if the fastest
easiest way was put some in mutual funds
i would do that
what's the fastest easiest surest
most proven way
fifteen percent of your income into
retirement
be funding your kids college fund baby
step five six is pay off your house as
soon as the house is paid off max out
all your retirement and you can save
like a crazy person and you've got all
kinds of cash flow and wiggle room in
your life
to do that's people that only have
enjoyment but also do incredible
investing yeah a lot of people don't
think about the fact that if you don't
have a house payment then you have all
of the cash flow and with all of that
you can invest all of it if you want to
and all of it's like all of it and then
you can become a millionaire times two
or three you know how fast you become a
millionaire without a house payment oh
my god the math is like
zero to 60. it's the fastest
easiest
most sure way
to wealth follow these baby steps that's
why we wrote babysit's millionaire to go
with the total money makeover with
financial peace it's it's this path that
is very clear and very proven
and we get to talk about it every day
this is the ramsey show